so what if you have a little bit of
mouse droppings on the beat who cares I
get 13 eggs
a Baker's Dozen uh they sell eggs in a
bag
hey daddies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
[Applause]
what's up buddy welcome to the new setup
but this is great sorry about you I'm
great I like that hair thanks man this
is a good time in Ryan's sick I know
you've been through it it's not a good
time
you're coming out of the other side of
it
this is a great year for you it's not a
great year everything's been awesome
statistically I'm batting 162 right now
okay yeah but everyone comes out of a
slump I do lead the majors in uh uh bun
singles
you're the Don Baylor of Comedy uh who
used to get hit in the ball guys
that dude got hit in the net during the
national anthem and nobody has a ball
you have to remember too statistically
if a million people play baseball one of
them is going to be the guy that's been
hit the most by the ball and he's the
guy
got a big old butt anyway uh no pleasure
to be here as always rough year for you
but special out and I love it so much
and we'll talk about it yeah you're only
going up you're only going up yeah
but your podcast is beautiful and
wonderful all good things going with
that yes please subscribe to the
Honeydew podcast please watch my special
Lefty son available on YouTube now
we'll get to all of it because there's
praise coming your way this is dumb
people town you know how this works
although it works a little differently
from the last time you've done it Dan's
got a story Jay's got a story then I
have a story we all sort of work it that
way it's stupid Behavior we try and
break down and understand why people act
the way they do and try and fight it
with comedy Daniel who's got the First
toys I do all right I also have
allergies so bear with me
listener this was presented by Kyle
Andrews at late night nachos love that
that's a great name at late night nachos
everyone's excited to see him
woman finds snake inside popcorn bag at
grocery store
speaking of Baltimore yeah no from uh
Diner well that he had something else it
was one eye it was nice
that's something you can't do in a movie
anymore uh anymore not too far
oh you're talking about the popcorn so
she found a snake in her popcorn
do we know what kind of snake
hold on though
complaint do you have if you haven't
bought it yet
right yeah who are you complaining like
in that case you're just it's the same
as being like hey someone dropped a jar
of tomatoes in aisle four what like was
that was it nobody's done anything to
use the bag of smart pot wiggling what's
happening
you guys have all done Garrett's right
Garrett's Popcorn in Chicago no I know
you guys are nuts on Clark I'm a nuts on
Clarks I mean they're fine they're great
they're fine what's Garrett's Garretts
there are people gonna come after you
saying what's here I know I know I'm not
coming upstairs why are you coming after
us wait I don't there's Popcorn Chicago
mix it's half caramel half cheese oh so
good so yeah I'm gonna dance big
Christmas tin you open up and it's got
the divider yeah the divider you take
that divider out just shake it out Dan
I'm gonna now piss everybody off from
Chicago a little bit more just because
I'm from St Louis I won't uh get into
Garrett's until it's shown on the series
The Bear
I bet it does show up I bet it does show
I just hung out with some people from
that cast I thought it was awesome but
nice uh yeah and uh Rami was uh
directing some of their episodes they
were all great great um okay
Kenbridge Virginia it's not too far
right not too far where's Cambridge you
know where that I mean
okay not near Baltimore trip to a
grocery store turned into a nightmare
for a woman in leave don't buy it and
leave Lunenburg County Virginia Kimberly
Slaughter come on now
you're either pro wrestling or you're
doing that
Kimberly Slaughter
on it right now Sergeant Corporal nine
snake pet snakes at home and she brought
one she's like I need I need I need to
bring me a loss I need some free [__]
mama needs some new drapes I'm gonna
duck this here we gonna get a free
Tombstone
Pizza
a cheese one too no toppings
I'm Gonna Roll that into the old but
you're right though if you see a snake
in a bag the move is buy it take it
outside then have the [__] fit you're
you have no argument if it's still in
this you're just letting them that's not
yours you're just helping with quality
you're just making a citizens arrest you
seeing it to me it's like if you ever uh
pack your cart full of stuff and then
walk to another aisle just because for
some reason your brain snaps and you're
like I'm just gonna leave everything
here as long as none of your stuff is in
it if someone takes that you can't be
mad they did take your time the amount
of time all they took that's all they
took but like that's not yours it still
belongs to the store this is why people
die on Black Friday because it's all in
the store anyway Kimberly Sergeant
Slaughter drops
somebody had to have someone had to
right yeah that's her name on the
bowling league that's the name that's
the snake's name and it's her pet and
you know there are people in her life
who just salute her for sure
dropped by Shoppers value
already sounds it's like apartment
complexes that are like Sunset Breeze
and you're like this is gonna people in
the Morningside Heights people only deal
drugs Cadbury Cadbury arms Canterbury
arms I have to say this though moving to
California where I grew up in Maryland
we had giant yeah we had Safeway yeah
sure we had
um amp sure
um and you get out here and the major
chain is something called Ralph's Ralph
it's just until you get used to it
you're like a euphemism for throwing up
where I'm gonna go buy my food well St
Louis we had one called Schnucks
Chinook sounds like they're trying to
get you yeah he snooked them in the back
see that snooked [__] Rochelle we had
Eagles Sullivans and Aldi's and then
Walmart Walmart killed them all yeah
except all these all these are still so
we used to do a bit about here in La
there's Vons
b-o-n-s Good Times yeah your deal and
then there's John's j-o-n-s where they
have a triangle in the J to make it look
like way lower rent is John you want
people just drive by like we need some
milk I'm just going to stop off at this
Vons over here and I just look quickly
there's no need to check a second time
I'm sure they're not trying to mess with
us and none of us talk about Smart and
Final we all know about it we've all
been in one a few times Smart and Final
is where you go when you want to clean
the bathtub afterwards I'll be honest
too when I used to live where I lived
deep in the valley and I'm not ashamed
to say I shopped at Food For Less food
food for less
food they don't even have the money to
spell out for it's like it's got to be a
number
three letters are you texting oh you are
yeah
I only have enough money for One camera
okay so she's Sergeant Slaughter
she was in the Shopper's value in
Cambridge to pick up a few groceries
when she noticed what she believed were
mouse droppings on a package a packaged
bag of popcorn leave it there again okay
don't touch it there is no need you are
engaging wait there's a scary sound
coming from inside the house I better
open the door and keep going in this is
not an invitation for you to investigate
first let's go see how deep that hole is
also who leans in it's like
it could be a chocolate chip you never
know
a loose it's either a loose chocolate
chip or a chicken in which case it's my
lucky day or just speaking back there on
the shells like it looks like this is
weird too here's what this is a quote I
was like I'm not getting that back
so I put it on the bottom shelf because
there was already Mouse Poop covering
the bottom shelves which means you you
don't want yo I'm not getting it but
then you picked it up and then you put
it under there yeah but I also think was
did this used to be a pet store
I would explain a lot right I mean
there's so much goddamn guinea pigs
reptiles in the back that's exactly I'll
put it right here next to the leashes
and this bag of shavings Slaughter said
there was sticky rodent traps on the
bottom shelf as well
oh my God why would you continue to go
back to that place go to a gas station
exactly seriously my cantaloupe is
sticking on something here
[Laughter]
have you ever walked into a gas station
and they have baskets yeah and I'm like
congratulations what legally separated
[__] walking around this game
and you know the story of the of the car
wash over on Prospect here and Vermont
that's my favorite thing ever you walk
in and like most of the car washes is
you're getting your car wash still have
like air freshener greeting cards floor
mats greeting cards but this one like
really expanded out they're like we have
like Italian loafers and Chinese
throwing stuff and bongs I'm like who is
the person that like this is their
One-Stop shop I need dress shoes I need
weapons that are you can throw at people
I need bongs well Slaughter said there
were sticky rodent traps on the bottom
shelf she then went to grab another bag
of popcorn at this point you've seen
Mouse dropping another shelf covered in
poop and a reptile well don't worry
about it yeah but we haven't seen it she
then went to grab another bag of popcorn
but noticed the bag had a small hole in
the top right corner we'll definitely
get that one that she cut herself
as soon as I went to put the bag in my
basket why you should I noticed it had a
hole are you gonna go up to the front
and be like can I get this for like this
is when someone there's a lot of holes
in this story yeah right it's too dumb
to even know how to lie yeah yeah so I
took the whole yeah I mean wait no I
mean that kind of as soon as I yeah well
hang on a second I mean what'd I say
what I said wait did I say I put this
when did I say I saw the whole snake in
there wait when did I say
you you tell me when I said what did it
would I kick the bag under the Shelf
with the mouse Roberts before after I
saw the hole what was on the table
when did I say it when did I say that
part I'm already getting two Jones
I've already put them in my cart
anytime I'm ever at a grocery store and
I see someone put frozen pizzas in their
cart first I'm like [__] yeah that is
last stop Frozen walk around with Frozen
stuff
this pizza has a bite out of it I don't
understand yeah yeah it's got a lion
bite she said with her mouth full of
food yeah uh okay where was I as soon as
I put the bag the bag in my basket to
take it up to the front because you know
they can't sell it the thing so she said
she she put it in her basket to go show
to that person because they can't sell
it you don't ma'am you don't work here
you don't work for this one you can also
say hey there's a hole in the bag that I
left it there can someone go deal with
it the thing popped out and you know I
was like this is quote Oh well hi that
thing was a snake Slaughter said she
immediately pushed her grocery cart with
the bag of popcorn and snake inside to
the front of the store to let an
employee know about the issue so you're
not that freaked out right
there because you put it like I ate a
couple handfuls I don't know why that's
bad oh hey you're not supposed to come
out now right oops get in there okay
they're like this doesn't ever happen
here she explained but the bottom shelf
has no merchandise on it because of the
simple fact that mice get on it while
she was at the front of the store
Slaughter said the snake crawled out of
the bag down the side of the shopping
cart before returning to the popcorn bag
which means this thing was like I'm
going back home it went down the Legos
hey that snake knows where it's popcorn
is buttered that's a Slaughter said it
had it was the full length of the cart
it had prime real estate though hold on
how big was the popcorn I mean are we
talking about a big bags
at the top yeah oh like a giant one yeah
the kind of you just like drag around
the house you get a free Roger flag with
it like that yeah
drag that popcorn over here I'm gonna
take a bath drag it over here the
employee uh a quarter solder employee
removed the snake from the store I have
a baby and he is just starting to walk
so imagine if he was a little bit older
or if my niece had gone in and been like
hey I want some popcorn and grabbed that
bag and it bit her it's not there's so
many ifs in there so many like imagine
if my grandma hadn't died 10 years ago
today was my day to take her out to
lunch but the lunch place was close so
we came in here because she loved
popcorn and she has diabetes imagine
that yeah it's like we all can imagine
it it's never happening did that happen
no my kid's learning to walk but imagine
15 years from now when he's 16 years old
if he came in here like it's not 15
years so now man stop it was a full
length he's arriving now man he's
driving now not walking script station
wtvr reached out to the store manager
Brian Stanley he's put his two weeks in
here
he just [__] quit he's done he
retired he said that the reptile was a
small black snake we have no idea where
it came from he said we are
investigating trying to find out where
it came from but we have no other
indicating indication that there could
have been any others we are going to go
on This Woman's Instagram to see if she
has any questions
usually these snake people do have her
cat her her handle is the snake lady yes
AKA Medusa McGee yeah exactly okay it's
like in her hair Slaughters House of
snakes yeah uh we have no idea where it
came from we're trying to investigate
and find where it came from we have no
indication there could be any others
when asked about the rodent droppings
and traps Stanley said he wasn't aware
of any mouse traps at the store at the
time because he wasn't there that's a
good such a good you know those
mousetraps have been there for six
months I am not aware I'm not aware I
was not anywhere near there
no we're asking for the entire six
months no then he's like he does what
happens for the entire six months we're
asking her that well I don't have my
schedule on me you were there though at
some point I was not there today wasn't
there today he said that we use mouse
traps sporadically when we have a need
for them so not just for fun
but more so for prevention
you know we like to be preemptive yeah
what's the grocery store called
what
yeah yeah exactly a snake is eight thank
you Aaron that was the snake is a good
Mouse is the best mousetrap they could
have gotten moving that's their best
event that's why I put it in there I
mean I mean that's why I mean
yeah I haven't seen any traps but I mean
come on Jimmy Snuka
Slaughter said she's not sleeping lady
the poet laureate Slaughter said she
plans to report the incident to the
Virginia Department of Health to which
I'm sure they're gonna go fine
you're shopping at a whatever this place
is did anything at did you get bit no
but I could have right did your son get
I could have no I could have all right
[__] this lawsuit
I tried I tried yeah I tried to let this
did the snake attack you no I'm more
kidnapped the snake and took it to the
front so you engaged more with the snake
than it gauged with you right yes uh she
goes on to say this Sergeant Slaughter
she doesn't want the store to shut down
for good because it's one of the only
places to purchase groceries in the
small town
making it worse
we'll get out of here on this
based on 355 Google reviews what do you
think is the five-star rating for
Shoppers value in Cambridge Shoppers
value what do you think right I'm going
two and a half two and a half Stars I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go 3.75 yeah it's the
only place in town you get the 355. you
don't know any better I love that store
mouse trappings and all right I'm gonna
do four stars four stars yeah
end of story one Shoppers value on
Google has a review rating of
4.2
you know good prices
a little bit of mouse droppings on the
beat who cares I get 13 eggs
a Baker's Dozen uh they sell eggs in a
bag they sell it in a bag
eggs in a bag we got eggs in a bag and
that's how we do it here at Shoppers
value well you're buying 24 when you get
home there's going to be at least 18 of
them
it's a crap shoot uh all right so that's
first story down the book so come back
talk about Ryan's new special which is
out and it is so funny we've all seen it
we love it you will love it too we'll
talk about that in other dates and other
stuff we have going on right after this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show we uh
Ryan sickler is our guest his new uh
special is fantastic
Lefty son uh you can see the and you're
selling that merch aren't you that's a
great looking sweatshirt I wasn't I
literally made this because I took a
page out of Ari's book just because we
all get chit chatty and sometimes you
forget to say and everything so it's
right there that's why I did it but then
a lot of people hit me up like will you
please [__] sell it's like sell it
it's great I am selling it but I just
also I'm like unless you're literally
Lefty son what the [__] are you gonna
wear this for this actual no it's great
but it's no it's just it's cool maybe
your dad's or mom's left-handed I think
you should also do think about the moms
being like I think you should Steve
Carlton's niece
you should also do a like a Jesus
airbrush of you on tailgate Jesus
with that of you on stage from that
thing people buy that and put that on
their car or weed on the front alcohol
in the background uh I know how'd you
feel about how it's been out now as of
when we're recording this now this is
going to drop in the middle of May but
as we're recording this now been out for
a month a month yeah it's it's up near
600 500 600 000 views which is amazing
I'm very happy and proud of it I I was
able luckily DBK came and opened up yeah
he did the back an ounce he did the back
announce he brings me out on stage as
well yep and um
I don't know I'm lucky I got it done in
December because then all the health
[__] happened in January and I'm
literally in a hospital making notes
because I directed this thing myself I
produced it my uh good friend Sam vollen
did so much uh with it and
post-production and production as well
and you mentioned the dynasty such a
great place those guys are the [__]
great yep that was really
um stoked to shoot it there because I've
always liked the first time I went there
um
I love the theater and so when I was
looking I had Jamie up and he's like you
know let's do a middle of the week and I
was like I want to do in December I was
nervous about Christmas but Soul Bo
shows out they were [__] awesome
[Music]
um I really love how it turned out and
um yeah go watch it this is how you
support we said this over and over these
free specials are not free they're not
free to make but also they are free for
you to consume and it is a chance for
people who are who've created their own
jet stream and are flying through that
to reach out to more and more you could
see the power of the Honeydew behind
that too you know you built your podcast
into such a fantastic Juggernaut and if
you guys don't know it's podcast the
Honeydew people come on and tell stories
of basically like the worst moments of
their lives I like the low light you
like the low lights and they're so funny
because people are so vulnerable in
those moments you're so kind to them but
at the same time it's like how can you
not make fun just you asking questions
about why it's basically done people's
own dumb people Town yeah yeah there was
a clip of from your show where some guy
was talking about everyone bullied him
or called him gay
and you're like patreon right and you
were like so when did you come out of
the closet and he was like I'm not gay
she's like hey great oh wait so you were
openly out of that she's like Ryan I'm
not even gay and I just lost it and it
is it is but it's so funny your
curiosity and your ability to sort of
but then that comes through it like goes
hand in hand in the stand-up too you
feel it in the same energy yeah you've
basically created this this Lane for you
that you're doing this that's perfect
and it's so you as well which I love
you're you're engendering your own
audience and I could feel it in the
people who showed up to watch your your
special I'm sure all your fans of the
Honeydew freaking love this special yeah
it's been very well received
um you know you look at things like
likes and comments sure all that stuff
and
um it's overwhelming like it looks like
I paid people to say nice things like
it's you know because then they tell you
you got to get into com which I had
never done before get in the comments so
the get in and engage because that
pushes it out in the algorithm I'm like
Jesus Christ so now I gotta read the
comments of people [__] on me but it
was it was 50 to one yeah and I was like
hey you know you're gonna have the one
by the way knowing that there's the one
makes you love the 50 more yeah it's and
by the way having done the Honeydew and
all that other stuff it's like the
you're gonna get your own great story
yeah and also these [__] Slams are
nothing compared to the [__] we've heard
and talked about 100 unbelievable you
know give me a man you know like give me
a man not my thing you're like all right
good thanks for watching I'm not for
everybody so it's uh it was fun and it
was great to to I'm lucky to be able to
get that [__] thing out I've said it
on Santino's podcast but I call Tom
segor and
I was started crying I was like he's
like is there anything I can do and I
was like yeah
you could take my special put it on your
YouTube
give my daughter all the money don't put
it on my YouTube put it on your YouTube
channel
of course I I lived thank God if I
didn't I was like it goes to hear you I
think that's it that's her willing
people dude you lived and you're here
I'm so happy you're here thank you uh so
again Lefty son and subscribe to your
YouTube page so yeah and then you can
see you live where where can people say
go just go to ryansickler.com uh I'm I'm
starting my tour at the end of May I hit
Fort Wayne first I'm going to Tacoma in
June and then I'll be in I believe it's
Fort Wayne Tacoma and I can't even
remember right now because one of them
got rescheduled go to ryancycler.com and
tour starting it's called the live and
Alive tour I love it God you're alive
thank God uh for us we're going to be as
this drops this weekend we're going to
be in Minneapolis at the Acme Comedy
Company I love it one of my favorite
comedy clubs we haven't been there in a
while this is almost 19. let's sell all
these shows out I really want to it's
great comedy Town love this new hour
that we're doing so that's uh this
weekend and then uh we've got we'll be
in at Cobbs Comedy Club at the end of
July we're going to be in uh Ann Arbor
at the Ann Arbor comedy showcase we're
going to be at the comedy in September
comedy fort in October in Springfield in
November and we're going to add some
more dates to do it supersclores.com for
that and Daniel uh I have uh dates are
about to be announced at
danielvankirk.com otherwise if you
haven't already check out the patreon we
do your dumb news stories from your own
life and uh they're just fun it's a good
hang plus also we do things like uh
stuff we want to talk about in our own
life maybe even a little like food or uh
drink challenges and greenlies as well
no it's all it's all there and we've
brought it all down to one level uh
that's all five bucks it's five bucks
from Wisconsin in July and that's where
there it is
okay here we go uh this was sent in by
Eric James hiltner of course we are we
are I'm in the hip member of the Hill
neurons
it's been around for a long time he's
been doing that's at
ejh3 spelled out t-h-r-e-k uh here's the
headline woman removed from multiple
attractions at theme park as breasts
cause safety hazard wow for other people
that's my question for her or for other
people so I mean her breasts might be
okay so she removed from multiple ones
at once I'm guessing they can't close
the Dan you might be right right
one of the let's get into it real quick
do you know there's an entire thing of
uh like a tick tock of just people in
like slingshot thing yeah screaming and
pass out and wake up again is those and
then it's just women in low-cut shirts
doing it too and they just go back and
forth through people passing out and
low-key weird like yeah
sure I love it uh this is one of them
Ryan's like what is that send me that
link uh how do I get on that algorithm
one of the world's most well-known theme
parks is once again Under Fire for not
being completely accessible for all
types of guests and this time the paying
visitor was left completely quote
unquote mortified when the team member
brought up her chest in front of lines
of other people so were they mortified
or were they not oh yeah she was bored
she's probably like this never happens
at the Renaissance Fair no
this didn't happen in the red light
district this didn't happen at the wet
t-shirt contest I was participating in
last yes the guest press cause our body
at Hooters about this yeah they didn't
mention anything the guest press caused
a safety hazard at the theme park
leaving her unable to ride multiple
attractions of course theme parks
worldwide have numerous health and
safety measures and protocols have we
said what theme park this is they're not
saying it something I'm thinking herself
oh yeah they'll say it yeah
what's the one in Jersey that had the
Netflix specials
uh however the guests visiting Alton
Towers competitor Thorpe Park Resort
I'm gonna say that's in England
altered Alton Towers competitor Alton
Towers sounds like the theme park that
was created by the TV show Faulty Towers
it is in the United Kingdom uh did not
anticipate that her breast would make
her unable to ride multiple rides at the
Leisure Destiny I am only for only for
educational purposes do you have a
picture of this person oh yeah there
will be well that's a good question yeah
because it's important and maybe it's in
there so you don't have to answer but
are they her natural breasts or are they
fake titties hold on I feel like they're
100 natural I don't agree but if you if
they're natural you gotta let you got to
figure out how to let this lady enjoy
the rides
if it's not able to come down just like
if someone is too big too wide to ride
the ride they can't get on yeah
over the top
so she can get her kid back she turns
her hat around no no no she turns her
tits around backwards that's so she can
get her kid back I'm telling you you
face the seat you pull your tits in hard
I feel I I want this woman to what if
she's like a coaster fan I want her to
enjoy it speaking to the sun Ellie Scott
and I'm not going to tell you how old
she is with us later reported that her
size what breasts okay what size are
these I'm gonna go I'll go Triple J okay
what's that what you have to give a
number first what oh like her her I'm
gonna go 45
40 48 Double D I'm gonna go 46 Triple J
46 and 48 so I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
44.
[Music]
um
triple F ready yeah get your answers in
town you shout at your ham radio she's a
b cup size 38 e that's not even
that is that that big
yeah
a little better than the four of us and
the four of us to talk about breasts
like we are
large that's a large press but I guess
it speaks more to the ride right yeah
right so well it's caused her to visit
to Thor Park found in Surrey England to
become completely unenjoyable causing a
state of embarrassment and relatively
from whose perspective unused how
expensive was the ticket I think she
should be able to she should have to get
Summer money back at least dollars
I'll do the dollar 199
199.86 186 48 bucks 48 bucks get your
answers in 230 dollars wow expensive
ticket to not feel is that a high hold
on is that a hopper it's a park hopper
so this is a court this is your
experience
you get the water park with that
she'd get on the water right she can get
on the water right no problem that is
encouraged by the way she went on
Silicon Mountain
um Ellie uh Cara Elliot was allowed to
board the Swarm stealth and Nemesis but
had to get off each ride because the
safety restraints would not click into
place which also was super annoying
because she waited in that line she
waited the whole line because you know
sometimes they have at the very
beginning they have like sit in here and
if it were to hide things before you go
all with it you can see I've never seen
a sit I have yeah
it'll happen to throw your carry-on in
that thing right now if it doesn't fit
you don't get it that's right you have
those
Six Flags
yeah 100 okay well so Disney might do it
too Ellie who has visited 40 theme parks
before without issue was told in front
of cures your chest is too big
are we really gonna stake an entire
theme parks reputation on the guy who or
who who's running the ride right this
guy right is lucky to be out of rehab
this guy is lucky to be on out not like
he's not going to be in rehab he is
lucky like we're just lucky he's not
whipping out his dick and peeing
everywhere he's getting paid like 13
bucks 13 bucks maybe he's self-cutting
in the booth as he's going through this
what he's doing and yet he's saying your
chest is too big speaking the truth
which is honest he didn't have to say
and I personally prefer small breasts
yeah he didn't have to add that he's
part of it that was a little I don't
know if they have underestimate uh
underestimated boob sizes here I'm a cup
size e but I don't think that's massive
I was wearing a normal black sweater so
I have no idea where the explanation
came from her husband Josh was told by
Thorpe Park employees to bring someone
else next time no
there you go bring someone else next
time now there's where the guy stepped
across absolutely it's the same guy yeah
it's I I'm assuming it's one guy the
again the problem for the husband is he
engaged in that conversation he's like
well who else should I bring well also
they could be leaving out the contest
guys yeah band Dan in his pocket and a
hip chain he doesn't give up okay
get your titties out of here all right
guys we all clicked in back up all right
keep your hands inside at all times here
we go let's go and then who's ready
he goes to the coke now
by the way
conspiracy theory is fully he thinks her
husband is having an affair she told the
park to not let her ride just so we
could get to the line you could bring
someone else because he's so dumb he'd
be like like who else if I was dating
someone
there you go man we are leaving out the
possible contact
like he could have steered the
conversation that way yeah like he's
like what am I supposed to do I want to
ride with my friend when I come here and
you're not letting my wife go then they
go well then bring somebody else like if
you if you have like who like who else
should I who else should I bring the
woman you brought yesterday I thought
you were working
yesterday's fit get your backpack
sunglasses and gear on the side we're
not responsible for any loss items click
it tight let's go hands inside
yeah
do not raise your hands
can you Dolly pardon me watch a loose
change hey fire in the hole
let's light this candle now this guy's
still over here yelling out about his
wife's titties watching it's just the
track in there now he's like come on man
these are the two minutes I live for bro
this is my life this is my life this is
my ride on this thing because we lose
one person I got out of a job I sleep in
a tent outside
the couple was refused a refund for
their tickets but offered a chance to
return to the theme park to reuse them
at a later date what's the point that
gonna help she still can't get on the
rides can't get on the ride unless she
gets a breast reduction well she's got
some work to do uh Thorpe Park Resort
from Merlin entertainment's promises
infinite Thrills and exhilarating
experiences you cannot promise infinite
Thrills those are Thrills that don't
ever stop shootout oh yeah she got what
they got Walking Dead The Ride Darren
Darren Brown's ghost train I love what
the hell is Darren Brown Brown
was Darren Brown UK folk hero uh did
Darren Brown hit Rihanna's brother rise
of the demon Black Mirror Labyrinth ooh
Black Mirror flying fish the Rumba
Rapids there she can get on that water
right from Rapids Oregon
Inferno and UK's fastest roller coaster
stealth across eight different
territories such as the Angry Birds land
oh yeah lost city Amity original Amity
cave the new roller coaster in Old Town
under the name project Exodus will open
in 24. get your breasts ready have you
ever been in Bear does have a water park
there you go there you go nice looking
Lazy River and then and then it says
have you ever been embarrassed by a
Theme Park employee in front of others
let us know comments below uh I don't
think any of us have I have have you
really what is it I was in high school
yeah back then they would have remember
the shirts your you guys are old enough
like me they would be like um C dick
drink C dick Fall Out Boy
sure and then they would have like big
dog on the porch or whatever well that
was a [__] punk high school kid right
no parents at 17. I had one of those on
I think it was two dogs like doggy style
or whatever just like a big dogs
whatever yeah but I'm in line for the
Rebel Yell at the King's Dominion and it
was the Midnight Hour they pulled me
they went on they pulled me aside and
they tell me that my shirt is
inappropriate and that if I don't turn
inside out at the minimum then I cannot
ride the rides and I have a huge
argument with him about it and they
don't want to hear it and they basically
embarrassed me in front of me wow why
wouldn't you just turn it inside out I
mean I did you did I did but I was also
17 yeah
right and don't you [__] this is
whatever it is and I don't even know
what amendment
but y'all just you guys man the Rebel
Yell goes backwards now so I'm gonna
turn this inside out I'm gonna lose my
place in line that's how I got to as
long as I'm next you got me I'm next
that's crazy I don't know that we've
ever been embarrassed uh I got another
one for you I got another good one
Carnival one can I see
as we know are just all run by meth
addicts and everything derelicts like
that's how they put it up so fast and
break teeth don't worry about their
teeth yeah everything else is done so at
the time I lived near
um uh open field in Sherman Oaks where
they were having a you know one of those
carnivals that'll come by for put it up
and um two of my friends they live up
the block and they want to go and
they're like will you come with us
they're both girls and I go yeah I'll
come with you but I'm not riding the
rides anymore I don't now I'm you know
the worried I see it yeah you know what
it is yeah like they're gonna go on it I
wouldn't go on it you know I go these
are [__] people that they're carnies
yeah some [__] goes down tomorrow night
they're gone that [__]
I don't I don't ride anything that folds
into a truck eight yeah
that's it oh yeah that's it so um
they're like we're still gonna go I'm
like do your thing and I'm not kidding
you as we're walking up okay there's the
swings right here oh God and right next
to it's the zipper the yellow cage that
you know go yeah
and we're walking up and I hear a fire
truck and an ambulance go by and I'm
joking I'm like probably coming here but
they pass
but it's a good one they [__]
u-turned
no because they passed the carnival and
now they're coming across the grass and
I'm like what the [__] and as I look
over right here's the zipper the one
girl's already on she's already eating
yeah she's already in there with that
awkward seat you know you're tilting
forward yeah just waiting for somebody
to get into they can just shut this cage
and fire it and just send her up
awkward lead that like rocking forward
yeah well hurry up get it get it yeah so
just as my friend Christy's about to get
in she had a ponytail never forget this
I look over and there's a [__] woman
laying flat no lifeless on the ground no
okay and I yank Christy's ponytail and I
go look and she's like oh my God and the
[__] zipper guy she's laying right
here in the guy at the zipper you know
what he's doing two ticket let's go
let's go let's lower up two tickets
like are you this ladies laying around I
know mine I'm not kidding okay pay no
money
[__] zipper I'm like why the swing's
off and I'm like so did she fly off the
[__] swing like you know what I'm
saying the swing is not running
everything else is running lights are
dark at the swing already you know the
chains are coming down already they're
breaking it they're [__] breaking it
down wait a minute just went up hold up
we just bring it online they're just
laying poles around by the woman is
laying face down they come in they get
this lady and they [__] [__] ass out
of there I have no idea what happened
you remember the Gravitron oh yeah yeah
in Rochelle in Rochelle at May Mark
Commons they had set up the whole
parking lot they did a whole Carnival
sure I'm on the Gravitron it was the
worst it's the last time I've ever been
on one for real it doesn't know it spins
around so fast you're just up against
the wall and you can kind of do whatever
you want all the way around go upside
down and [__] oh God three down for me
person on the Gravitron they just start
throwing up and it's just going right
back into their own face right right and
then they stop and they get that person
off they clean it this is like halfway
through the ride and the person who runs
the Gravitron is like a ba like they
just think they're the shits meow right
yeah and so they're [__] they're like
doing moves and stuff on the Gravitron
which the core strength alone like yeah
so at one point the guy who was running
I think probably a 17 18 year old kid
right just looking for his dad he's like
he's something he didn't know yeah yeah
he's he's against the wall and he has
his feet against all he is straight out
perpendicular from the wall he looks
like Superman get the [__] out yeah he's
staying up
he had all these he had all these tricks
and things that he would do right
because he knew the ride and he was in
charge and I'm sure it got he was able
to every weekend I'm sure fingered two
chicks as human beings we could actually
if you fast enough you could do that
because yeah you have the strike you
have to like keep you're essentially
probably pushing the whole time against
from your eyes and then straightening
right so the problem was is when you get
on this thing you we walk around and you
find your spot right yeah and so you're
gonna see right away where this is going
there's a railing that you are like
holding on to before you get on your
thing so he's out perpendicular from the
wall it's spinning around and he looks
so cool but what he didn't think about
is that because we had stopped halfway
through his clock and his head of how
long the ride was oh it was off and so
all of a sudden it stops and he goes
face for
I watched this person throw up into
themselves and then I watch this guy
curb himself onto a thing every ticket
let's go let's go paying on my step over
the man yeah over the man he doesn't
work here anymore he doesn't work here
anymore I'm here he's not from here man
two tickets uh all right we're gonna
guess how old this woman is I'll show
you a picture of her there she is her
tits are not too big to get on her eyes
she is okay uh how old is that lady 33
33 29. 29. I'm sticking with 35. 35
years old get your answers in shout out
your ham radios this woman who had who's
got pulled off of many rides and offered
a chance to come back to a place where
she cannot go on many Rides Again sure
27 years
down the books I'll give you a little
taste of what we're going to hear in
Story number three a drinking game gone
wrong in China oh a drinking game gone
wrong in China's our guests his new
special is called Lefty's son you can
watch it on YouTube for free comment
send around rate it share get that algo
rhythm going and uh don't mind the dead
lady on the ground just step up two
tickets we'll be right back
all right gang welcome back to the show
I'm gonna take us home shall we do this
here we go sent in by Matthew Miller at
dust underscore from underscore Stars
okay thank you Matthew Miller thank you
a newer one but I believe he's sent in
before
two women padlocked their necks together
and threw the key down the toilet oh my
God what a nightmare XI Jiang China two
women in Eastern China had to turn to
Firefighters after padlocking their
necks together does that mean like a
biking on the toilet that's what I'm
wanting yeah I think in a drinking game
they liked it yeah they both lost you
know that old drinking game called um
getting drunk yeah what is the game you
know what though not to buy her now on
this uh love Barn Allen yeah this is
your bit man
alcohol makes you do this weed would
never make it happen next to yours if
you if we were both highest Kites and
for any reason I was like you want to
lock our next he'd go no no that's too
much work you're trying to give me
you're trying to give me a panic attack
exactly like alcohol alcohol be like
let's see yeah
like weed has the ability put that key
in a Ziploc bag
you say out loud three times I put this
key here and then write a note to put by
your bed in case you wake up in your
hand where you put the geek I'm gonna
write it on your face because I'm going
to be looking at it right here
can you imagine that or even head to
head is not great if we back to back
would suck do you know the Randy and I
in a movie in Bubble Boy the movie
we came in an auditioned for this movie
to play siamese twins and we were like
Randy they said what's your idea for it
and we just started riffing in the room
like what if like one woman was one was
a transitioning to a woman and the other
was a transvestite and the other was a
uh Orthodox Rabbi because we're like
just the idea that the rabbi had to go
through rabbinical school with this
person connected to the Head what if
they were connected at the head so
they're like that's great that's so
funny because we were part of this like
group of of freaks of freaks in the
freak Show so the head thing was the
freak part
Jewish rabbi also freaky
um so we they agree to do it and they
build a prosthetic that has like a thing
that locked into place inside the
prosthetic so we couldn't we literally
were stuck together for hours on the set
insane so I can't even imagine why I
would do this like and then get drunk
but using the toilet everything
everything driving drunk because they
were drunken because of drinking in the
drinking people say Do You Hear What
that key said to you yeah right here we
say you better flush that down what if
one of them's a raging alcohol the other
one just is not not at all Stone Cold
Sober yeah come on you [__] so
this was a popular uh drinking game that
became popular on Chinese social media
that may be the most unbelievable fact
about this whole thing that there is
social media in China there is it's
called Tick Tock according to the paper
the unnamed woman uh women in what
decade of their life do you want to do
it now they're in their 20s in their 20s
what do you think
30s teens
get your answers in they're in their 20s
I mean Province caused the public uproar
after chaining their necks together in a
game of life and death public uproar
public uproar by the way life and death
sounds like just the regular life of a
woman in China it sounds like the squid
games maybe if it will on November 18th
the Hangzhou fire department received a
report that two women were in trouble at
a restaurant and had quote lost the key
and at a restaurant restaurant and
padlock chain they were wearing around
their necks after one of them flushed it
down the toilet after desperate but
futile search for the key firefighters
had to cut the chain with bolt cutters
footage shows the firefighter holding
two women while a colleague frees them
with bolt cutters according to South
China Morning Post holding them did they
have to stroke their hair that was I
feel like I mean that is like you don't
pet these no but I think probably had to
separate them as much as possible
probably flying in their face who knows
or firefighters in China as hunky as the
firefight
this is a different city I want to make
that clear the firemen that I have seen
and dealt with in Santa Monica ripped
ripped good looking man yes built looked
like they can climb a [__] that's
right hold a hose handle Burbank here as
well same thing back home in Maryland no
we had to volunteer fired that's a
different thing and you would hear the
siren
and then they would haul ass and it
would just be out of shape people yeah
that were 400 [__] pounds they come
there with the stretcher and you're like
oh man we're gonna die we're gonna do
you like died you might die hauling me
over there it's like the Army Reserves
we come in on the weekends the women the
women this is a beer league fire
department that's right yeah the women
bought an iron chain and lock online
then asked the guests sitting next to
them to put the chain around their necks
as they walked in the restaurant from a
local pub I would do that would you do
this chain them up 100 one of the
firefighters said we discovered later
that the two girls had asked a male
stranger at the next table uh to lock
their necks and iron chains not a weird
thing to ask a stranger right and by the
way stranger turns back to his family
they want him they want to do that
nothing like the idea that I mean how
many I change your necks together I let
them grind on my lap they wanted me too
but honey why are you mad
I'm telling you guys this is I say this
is my thing as comics
you always say yes to it the gold if
somebody I was like thank you for this
15 minutes always say yes like if I saw
if I was in the room and they asked
someone else to do it I'd be so pissed
oh I'll do it I would need to insert
myself in this story somehow totally so
what percentage of dudes for real I
don't have the answer here do you think
if asked by two random 100 we're like
will you chain our necks together and
lock it for fun right I mean they're
making it they're cute what percent
ninety percent of 13. I think 100 no
matter what I mean obviously it's never
a hundred five percent be like [__] get
away yeah yeah but it's in the night
it's in the 90s especially if they're
saying like oh we're doing this goofy
thing it's for fun and it comes back to
us I tried to tell him no honey I tried
to tell them they were very Relentless
one of the women flushed the key down
the toilet uh and they returned to their
table to continue drinking wait is that
part of the challenge so I guess you
have to drink while you're tied with
your necks together as well the
bewildered restaurants to have
volunteered to assist to break the chain
with pliers but the women declined
saying that it would be against the
rules of the game I don't think people
are making these rules up if you go to a
restaurant
I don't know meanwhile the dude who put
the chain around the guy's neck said he
would drive each of them home is that
weird isn't that strange she was like of
course
some chicken fried steak
and I'll take you home I'll take you
some they don't have a place they don't
have a place honey you guys take an Uber
I'll take these gifts yeah you sleep in
the bed tonight honey and I'll be
hanging out with them and doing anything
honey
now I'm just gonna help him look for
that key huh listen I may be home in a
couple of days
this might be a three-necker right here
honey
three texts Jane together
no I didn't drink
yet
that's not my
my role is to make sure neither of these
people cheat that's it I wanted to get
chained up oh oh so you want them to die
that's why there's a whistle of mine you
got four minutes and the Uber's coming
it'll be here in four minutes that's why
there's a ball in my mouth honey in
about two minutes I'm not gonna be able
to talk anymore because they're
strapping this ball in my neck
[Laughter]
no I don't know why either I I don't
know why either yeah look I don't know
what I don't know I got you to excel
Uber xl's coming do you want to get in
the chain because we can get you in the
chain there's this room
sounds like you don't want to be in the
chain
oh he said he wants to stay something
yes I'm coming home
I don't know these girls I'm trying to
be nice
this is how the game goes you on Tick
Tock as the story was widely published
in mainland China the woman experienced
public criticism one online commenter
said don't they have anything better to
do it's just confusing please don't
waste public resources the firefighters
are already busy no the firefighters
left two burning buildings with people
in them yeah and they called for backup
right as alcohol consumption Rises at a
steady rate in China drinking games are
becoming more and more popular among
young people in the country in one such
game called guessing toothpick that's a
game participants must estimate how many
toothpicks a player is holding so this
is just raining man that's a jelly bean
that's right the person who gets close
in another game called game players take
turns counting whoever shouts out a
multiple of seven must drink
what you just take turns counting and if
you shout out a multiple of seven so you
are 49 yeah I love that it's just called
game God could you imagine if we could
go to China now and just show them flip
cup
quarters
revolutionized that just I mean
questions oh my God the Bismarck I love
that like all of Schwartz figliano
Schwartz figliano and Smith that all of
China is basically like a high school
senior right now yeah with like drinking
games for the first time it's like you
know I just they are like Amish kid on a
rum Springer like they've not been out
yeah this is their chance to get out and
do all the dumb stuff and they're gonna
get a mess down that is it all right I
love it there you go that is that was a
good one I love that tears in my eyes
tears of joy tears of laughter as it
always is with Ryan Lefty son that's the
special go to YouTube right now watch it
on his page subscribe to his page listen
to honeydew this is just one of our
favorite people in the world Ryan
sickler thanks for coming on thank you
guys for real thank you all happy you're
hearing happy you're here and healthy
and doing this of course and oh [__] we
gotta get back to work
[Music]